What exactly are you suggesting?
(SINGING) Mr.
Bright, Mr. Bright,
you are in for such a treat.
I have got some little dolls--
darling sprouts-- here abouts
that I'd love for you to meet.
Step right up.
Sir, welcome to the
Bright's butcher shop.
What can we get for you today?
Have you any ham?
Ah! (SINGING) Courtesy of Sam.
How about veal?
Yes, (SINGING)
thanks to Camille.
Kidney?
(SINGING) Sydney.
Belly?
(SINGING) Kelly.
Lamb?
(SINGING) That's Pam with
some jam or mint jelly.
I'd love some ground beef.
(SINGING) Well then,
sir, you're in luck.
Which do you prefer?
We've got Patty or Chuck.
[LAUGHTER]
Have you any mutton?
That would be Sutton.
Perhaps some foie gras?
(SINGING) Voile, see Francois.
Baloney?
(SINGING) Tony.
Salami?
(SINGING) Tommy.
And we've also got Reuben
if you like pastrami.
But do you have mincemeat?
(SINGING) Well,
since meat is sparse,
we've got Vince meat instead
sliced right off of his--
Caldwell, please, there
are children present.
Not for long.
No, because we're going to kill
them and sell them as meat.
[LAUGHTER]
Hey.
(SINGING) Ain't got no dad.
Ain't got no mom.
But are they sad
or are they glum?
(SINGING) No, they come
from a world that's
boiling with the sweetest
smiles you've ever seen.
Oh, they're good enough to eat.
Delicious!
(SINGING) A job well done--
--is, oh, so rare.
When Santa sung--
--the cupboard's bare.
So bare.
Before these darlings
get much thinner,
I think we ought to
make them dinner.
Oh, they're good enough to eat.
Supper time!
[BELL RINGING]
Careful!
Oh, I could take an eye out!
(SINGING) We may
not be respectable,
but we are so delectable.
Don't mean to be
presumptuous, but truth
is we are scrumptious.
Cakes and candies--
they're half as sweet.
Ooh, we're good enough to eat.
[WHISTLE]
(SINGING) Ain't got no dad.
We may not be respectable.
Ain't got no mom.
But we are so delectable.
But are they sad?
Don't mean to be presumptuous--
Or are they glum?
--but truth is we
are scrumptious.
No, they come from
a world that's
boiling with the sweetest
smells you've ever seen.
Ooh, they're good enough to eat.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TAPPING]
(DRAWN-OUT SINGING)
(SINGING) When times is hard--
When times is hard--
--you must make do.
Pull out of a blonde.
Pull out a blonde.
Try Mary Lou.
And try her brother too.
Yes, when you lack
a key ingredient,
substitutes become expedient.
Ooh, they're good enough--
though they're kind of tough--
ooh, they're good enough to eat.
Good to eat!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Eat-- good to eat!